In the previous
video, we observed
that Age and FrancePopulation
are highly correlated.
But what is correlation?
Correlation measures the
linear relationship between two
variables and is a
number between -1 and +1.
A correlation of +1 means
a perfect positive linear
relationship.
A correlation of -1 means
a perfect negative linear
relationship.
In the middle of
these two extremes
is a correlation
of 0, which means
that there is no linear
relationship between the two
variables.
When we say that two variables
are highly correlated,
we mean that the absolute
value of the correlation
is close to 1.
Let's look at some examples.
This plot graphs
WinterRain on the x-axis
and Price on the y-axis.
By visually inspecting
the plot, it's
hard to detect any
linear relationship.
But it turns out that the
correlation between WinterRain
and Price is 0.14.
So there's a slight
positive relationship
between these two variables.
This plot has HarvestRain on the
x-axis and the Average Growing
Season Temperature
on the y-axis.
It's again hard to visually
see a linear relationship
between the two variables,
and it turns out
that the correlation is -0.06,
even closer to 0 than before.
This plot shows Age of
the Wine on the x-axis
and the Population of
France on the y-axis.
We can easily see that there's
a strong negative linear
relationship between
these two variables.
This makes sense, since
the population of France
has increased with time.
If we compute the
correlation, we get -0.99.
So these two variables are
indeed highly correlated.
Let's compute some
correlations in R.
We can compute the correlation
between a pair of variables
in R by using the cor function.
Let's compute the correlation
between WinterRain and Price.
So we type cor, and
then in parentheses we
give the names of the
two variables, WinterRain
and Price.
If we hit Enter, this
function tells us
that the correlation between
the two variables is 0.137.
Let's look at another example.
This time we'll
compute the correlation
between Age and
FrancePopulation.
So again, we use
the cor function,
but this time we give
as the two variables
Age and FrancePopulation.
As we saw earlier, Age
and FrancePopulation
are highly correlated with
a correlation of -0.99.
We can also compute
the correlation
between all pairs of
variables in our data
set using the cor function.
To do so, we just type cor, and
then our data set name wine.
The output is a grid of numbers
with the rows and columns
labeled with the
variables in our data set.
To find the correlation
between two variables,
you just need to find
the row for one of them
and the column for the other.
For example, we can
find the column for Age
and then go down to the
row for FrancePopulation
to see the number
that we just computed.
Or we could check
if WinterRain is
highly correlated with any
other independent variables
by looking at the
WinterRain column.
So how does this
information help
us understand our
linear regression model?
We've confirmed that Age and
FrancePopulation are definitely
highly correlated.
So we do have multicollinearity
problems in our model
that uses all of the available
independent variables.
Keep in mind that
multicollinearity
refers to the situation when
two independent variables are
highly correlated.
A high correlation between
an independent variable
and the dependent
variable is a good thing
since we're trying to predict
the dependent variable using
the independent variables.
Now due to the possibility
of multicollinearity,
you always want to remove
the insignificant variables
one at a time.
Let's see what
would have happened
if we had removed both Age and
FrancePopulation, since they
were both insignificant
in our model
that used all of the
independent variables.
We'll call this
new model model5,
and again, we'll
use the lm function
to predict Price using
as independent variables
AGST, HarvestRain,
and WinterRain.
Again, we'll use
the data set wine.
If we take a look at the
summary of this new model
and look at the
Coefficients table,
we can see that
AverageGrowingSeasonTemperature
and HarvestRain are
very significant,
and WinterRain is
almost significant.
So this model looks pretty good,
but if we look at
our R-squared, we
can see that it dropped to 0.75.
The model that includes Age
has an R-squared of 0.83.
So if we had removed
Age and FrancePopulation
at the same time, we would have
missed a significant variable,
and the R-squared of our final
model would have been lower.
So why didn't we
keep FrancePopulation
instead of Age?
Well, we expect Age
to be significant.
Older wines are
typically more expensive,
so Age makes more intuitive
sense in our model.
Multicollinearity reminds
us that coefficients
are only interpretable
in the presence
of other variables being used.
High correlations can
even cause coefficients
to have an unintuitive sign.
We'll see an example of
this in the next lecture.
So we fixed the
multicollinearity issue
caused by Age and
FrancePopulation.
Do we have any other
highly-correlated independent
variables?
There is no definitive
cut-off value
for what makes a
correlation too high.
But typically, a
correlation greater than 0.7
or less than -0.7 is
cause for concern.
If you look back at all of
the correlations we computed
for our data set, you
can see that it doesn't
look like we have any other
highly-correlated independent
variables.
So we'll stick with
model4 for the rest
of this lecture, the model
that uses AGST, HarvestRain,
WinterRain, and Age as
the independent variables.